Obliczenia kwantowe weszły w erę użyteczności,
co oznacza, że możemy zacząć używać komputerów kwantowych do rozwiązywania
realnych problemów, w tym takich, które są bardzo trudne
dla klasycznych komputerów.
Wspólnym motywem w obecnej erze
jest to, że problem zostaje rozwiązany
po raz pierwszy na komputerze kwantowym,
a potem ludzie znajdują sposób, żeby zrobić to samo na klasycznym
komputerze. Ten cykl klasycznych
i kwantowych obliczeń wzajemnie wypychających się na granice
swoich możliwości będzie prawdopodobnie trwał
jeszcze kilka lat. Istnieją klasy problemów, w których obliczenia kwantowe
mogą mieć udowodnioną przewagę
nad klasycznymi obliczeniami,
biorąc pod uwagę postępy w takich obszarach jak
redukcja błędów i liczba dostępnych qubitów.
Są też całe obszary zastosowań,
w których obliczenia kwantowe
mogą okazać się przydatne w relatywnie niedalekiej przyszłości.
Jednym z tych obszarów jest kwantowe uczenie maszynowe, czyli QML.
Kwantowe uczenie maszynowe odnosi się do
zastosowania obliczeń kwantowych do dowolnego rodzaju uczenia
maszynowego. Istnieje oczywiście
wiele rodzajów uczenia maszynowego.
Dwa rodzaje szczególnie interesujące to
uczenie nadzorowane, w którym
trenujesz algorytm na oznaczonym zbiorze danych,
i uczenie nienadzorowane, w którym
algorytm pracuje na nieoznaczonych próbkach
i próbuje poznać rozkład
albo funkcję, która go generuje.
Algorytm nienadzorowany może na przykład
nauczyć się generować nowe próbki
z tego samego rozkładu albo jak
grupować próbki w klastry o podobnych cechach.
Zarówno uczenie nadzorowane, jak i nienadzorowane często wiąże się
z osadzaniem danych w przestrzeniach wyższych wymiarów.
Manipulowanie danymi w przestrzeniach wyższych wymiarów
powinno nasuwać nam myśl o obliczeniach kwantowych.
Pozwólcie, że wyjaśnię. Wyobraźcie sobie problem polegający na tym, czy
sklasyfikować punkt danych z płaszczyzny
jako okrąg czy krzyżyk na podstawie oznaczonych danych treningowych.
Czasem dane można wyraźnie rozdzielić linią
lub płaszczyzną w niskich wymiarach,
jak tu pokazano, i klasyfikowanie tych punktów danych według
tego, czy są powyżej linii,
czy poniżej linii, nie powinno być
żadnym problemem. Ale spójrzcie na ten rozkład —
wyraźnie nie ma żadnej widocznej linii, która rozdziela punkty danych.
Jednak dla tych danych możemy sobie wyobrazić jakieś
odwzorowanie z dwóch wymiarów do trzech wymiarów,
takie, że po zastosowaniu odwzorowania nasze dane wyglądają
tak i wyraźnie istnieje płaszczyzna rozdzielająca te dwie
klasy, której możemy użyć
do klasyfikacji. Jeśli to podejście wydaje się trochę uproszczone,
macie rację — nie możemy po prostu przesunąć punktów danych wyżej
bez żadnego uzasadnienia.
Musi istnieć odwzorowanie
z rozkładu 2D, które skutecznie rozdziela
nasze punkty danych, żebyśmy mogli
używać tego odwzorowania do klasyfikowania nowych punktów danych.
Będzie to omówione bardziej szczegółowo w lekcji poświęconej
podsumowaniu uczenia maszynowego, ale wystarczy powiedzieć,
że problem można postrzegać
jako próbowanie wielu różnych odwzorowań w tej wyższowymiarowej
przestrzeni, żeby zobaczyć, które odwzorowania dają najlepsze
rozdzielenie punktów danych różnych klas.
Ta manipulacja danymi w wyższych wymiarach
to jeden z obszarów, w których obliczenia kwantowe
mogą mieć duży wpływ. Żeby zrozumieć dlaczego,
wróćmy do różnic między klasycznymi
a kwantowymi obliczeniami. Tak samo jak
klasyczne komputery używają bitów informacji,
komputery kwantowe używają qubitów.
Ale dla danej liczby bitów, powiedzmy czterech,
klasyczny komputer może przyjąć dowolny z
dwóch do potęgi cztery, czyli szesnastu możliwych stanów.
Komputer kwantowy może też mieć dostęp do szesnastu możliwych stanów,
ale może istnieć w superpozycji wszystkich
szesnastu stanów jednocześnie,
a operacje mogą być wykonywane na całej tej superpozycji.
W przypadku czterech qubitów może się to nie wydawać
wielką sprawą, ale wyobraź sobie, co można by zrobić z
komputerem kwantowym mającym dwa do dwudziestu lub
dwa do stu dwudziestu siedmiu
stanów jednocześnie. Jest wiele innych różnic
między klasycznymi a kwantowymi obliczeniami, które
wszystkie odegrają rolę w tym temacie.
Stany kwantowe mają zespolone amplitudy prawdopodobieństwa,
manipulacje układami kwantowymi są przeprowadzane za pomocą
operatorów unitarnych, a komputery kwantowe podlegają innym
rodzajom szumów niż klasyczne komputery.
Te różnice będą się pojawiać
w całej twojej pracy z kwantowym uczeniem maszynowym, w obszarach
takich jak kodowanie danych, mapowanie cech i mitygacja błędów.
W niektórych przypadkach te różnice między klasycznymi
a kwantowymi komputerami pozwalają nam projektować całkowicie
nowe algorytmy. No dobrze, to był bardzo krótki przegląd
połączenia dwóch niezwykle skomplikowanych dziedzin,
ale mam nadzieję, że dwie rzeczy są jasne.
Po pierwsze: uczenie maszynowe często rozwiązuje problemy
manipulując danymi w bardzo wysokich wymiarach.
Po drugie: komputery kwantowe są dobrze przystosowane
do manipulowania danymi w wysokich wymiarach
i robią to inaczej niż klasyczne systemy.
To powinno dać ci poczucie,
dlaczego uczenie maszynowe jest obiecującą dziedziną
dla zastosowania użytecznych obliczeń kwantowych.